around the world film audiences are
gathering at night in New York
in Chicago
- this Twilight already dressed -
together to make tomorrow's headlines
and another chapter of Hollywood history
live
from the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion in
Los Angeles California the 54th Annual
Academy Awards
probably shared with you by the Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences [ __ ]
you by
rev la
in his red one
people who help make the world a little
more beautiful and the Buick motorcar
division that you're doing dealers who
proudly adopts the 1982 Buicks
and the coca-cola company and your local
coca-cola Butler for big refreshment
coke is it Polaroid in fetters of 600
high speed film and the cameras that use
it
his back for 53 years creating people
have gathered for Hollywood's annual
celebration of film excellence there's
Mae West Cary Grant and Ginger Rogers
Don Ameche and Loretta Young Joan
Crawford wallace Beery Jean Harlow Greta
Garbo Claudette Colbert Joan Blondell
Shirley Temple
Darrel f7 Louis V Mayer Humphrey Bogart
and Lauren Bacall Jimmy Stewart happy
McDuck
we're Carson
George Sanders in Georgia keyboard Hoagy
Carmichael sensor recent on Martin
spring Byington and Charles covered
Ronald Reagan
Elizabeth Taylor the water Parsons
Broderick Crawford Kim Novak Marlon
Brando Doris Day Paul Newman John Wayne
wizened Vincente Minnelli Jane Fonda
Fred MacMurray and June Hebert Melvin
and Helen Gahagan Douglas Jean Moreau
and George Cukor Goldie Hawn Pat and
Eloise O'Brien shutter for John
Maximilian Schell
Jack Nicholson
Betty Grable Isaac hey Peter Finch James
Caan
Dinah Shore and Burt Reynolds James
comer Francis Ford Coppola Michael Caine
and MacDonald Carey Cicely Tyson lead
boomer
Billy Dee Williams
Charles Bronson and Jill Ireland Marcel
Marceau Raquel Welch
Peter clock
Paul McCartney Fred Astaire and Irwin L
Art Carney Felicia and Jack Lemmon again
this year crowds packed the plazas the
Los Angeles Music Center as today's
stars
I'm in the best
this composition endless love and a
presenter of the saw
mr. Roger Moore may be the handsomest
mandala in the incarnation of Jane
a presenter of a special award
miss meryl streep Oscar nominee this
year for French Lieutenant's woman
Oh
nomination Marsha Mason
Best Supporting Actress nominee for her
I'm lemon
long time MZ
as ambassador to the entire world
Diana Ross a presenter on
she joins Lionel Richie singing endless
love
mr. James cooker
only one
one of the funniest men honor
mr. Jim Henson genius be
wrong in all the Muppets to whom star on
tonight's show
mr. John Schneider television star and
singer
tonight's nominated song
Richard Heene Jim
says the Viking character
Carol Burnett star of last year's hip
young for season
any Best Actor nominee dr. Moore with
miss Lola via former Oscar winner for
in farmer's daughter
tonight Howard Rollins jr. first time
Oscar nominee for his role in Gregg
tired
this year poor
golden Park
they have now joined these members and
guests in the Academy inside the theater
you will too in a moment
ladies and gentlemen Oscar nominated
composer bill Conti conducts the Academy
Awards orchestra in the overture a
medley of memorable film scores
you
you
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences
writer/producer fay kanin
good evening and welcome this is a
banner year for movies I don't think
we've ever honored an array of films
with more diversity or power to move us
entertain us and to all the nominees who
are out there this is a chance for us
your colleagues to say how much we
admire your work the commitment you
brought to it the talent that made you
realize it so beautifully this year the
Academy Awards will be seen in 71
countries by over 300 million people
among them a hundred and fifty thousand
hearing-impaired persons who will be
seeing and hearing it for the first time
Australia is carrying the show live via
the Pacific satellite Porto Rico
Venezuela Brazil live via the Atlantic
satellite Canada and Mexico are picking
it up live a special satellite feed
tomorrow morning will beam the
International Edition to England Italy I
just have to stop there in awe at how
dazzling our communication systems have
become how close the whole world and how
Universal the appeal of motion pictures
in Greece a young journalist who
interviewed me assured me I know a lot
about your country and your people I
asked him when he last been here and he
said oh I've never been but I've seen
your movies I knew what he meant much of
what we know about each other we learn
from each other's movies they transcend
language and geography and speak people
to people in a way nothing else can that
gives those of us who work in this
remarkable medium and added
responsibility to let our movies mirror
the life around us with all its beauties
and all its warts laughing at its
idiocies as well as celebrating its
spirit and humanity and you are
audiences
have an obligation to to help us keep
the screen free and open and bold and
critical so that like my young friend in
Greece we can go on saying to each other
I know a lot about your country and your
people I've seen your movies
I now have the great pleasure of
introducing a gentleman who helps all of
us know ourselves better through his own
insights and his Wieck are charming and
handsome host for this evening Johnny
Carson
our silent screen descends
thank you that's very nice of you and
welcome to long day's journey in tonight
are you are all comfortable by the way
an usher will give each row a squeegee
would you please use it and pass it
along sad to think that right now
$40,000 worth of hairdos are floating
down the street outside
but as you know ladies and gentlemen
this is the 54th year of this award show
and coincidentally this is the 54th
award show of this year
I don't know about you but I think we
ought to get together next month after
the popcorn manufacturers golden bucket
Awards and coolers a while but is it's
hard to believe that the Academy has
been in existence for 54 years I mean
just thank you
if Columbia had put only $2,000 a year
into an IRA plan they
they wouldn't have had to sell out the
coca-cola don't worry about Colombia
they're gonna be just fine they're there
collecting a nickel deposit on every
film can this year but because of
changes like that in this town critics
have said that Hollywood is losing some
of its glamour and there may be some
truth to that as you know there's stiff
competition among the studios as to how
many Oscar nominations each one got so I
would I'd like to break it down for you
this year
Dauphin Western got 35 nominations
coca-cola got six Atari had eight and
Kinney shoes had three
as far as glamour is concerned there is
no lack of glamour here tonight this is
a lovely lovely your stunning audience
tonight I have never seen such gorgeous
designer gowns you uh you ladies borrow
them from the Smithsonian
that could be trouble but as you know
ladies and gentlemen tonight you will
see three hours of comedy music and
drama of course we will have to
interrupt the commercials once in a
while to give out some awards speaking
of awards I think the caliber of
nominees in every category tonight is
outstanding now just consider the acting
nominees alone said screen veterans as
Henry Fonda John Gielgud Katharine
Hepburn who would have thought that in
1982 Burt Lancaster would be voted Best
Newcomer speaking of film veterans
wasn't it great that James Cagney and
Fred Astaire returned to the screen to
entertain us through another depression
their body
you're plotting for Cagney and Astaire
or the depression no but people know
especially in this audience that the
Hollywood has economic problems too now
critics say that they're not hiring
minorities and films not true any actor
in this town that's working is in the
minority as it as a matter of fact right
now in India you can adopt the United
Artists executive
you know he sends him a picture in a
letter once a month letting him know how
he's doing over here
but I mean let's be honest things have
changed in this business I mean it's
matured especially the attitude among
the actives nowadays actors use crude
language obscenities four-letter words
but enough about the Screen Actors Guild
if you're my age when I was growing up
pictures seem to uh well to be more
innocent in those days but you can
believe it but the days of innocence are
now gone 1981 was the year for example
that Superman lost his virginity
Zorro went gay and Mary Poppins went
topless but in one memorable scene an
sob
Julie Andrews showed us that the hills
are still alive but no matter how many
things change most pictures are made to
the old fashioned formula boy meets girl
boy gets girl in today's pictures the
boy still gets the girl he gets her on
the kitchen table he gets her own an
airplane restaurant
I hope that joke when it gets to the
satellite they send it back
but as you know not every film that is
made lives up to its creators
expectations now for example MGM
released under the rainbow this year and
well frankly audiences weren't enthused
about it
in fact the theater owners had to
install speed bumps near the exit
I
and the legend the legend of The Lone
Ranger was not not a biggie either but
there was one great scene in the legend
of the Lone Ranger where where Tonto put
his ear to the ground and said Kemosabe
I hear eight maybe nine people coming to
see this movie talks but of course next
year we can look forward to a fresh crop
of new and original films Superman three
Deathwish three rocky for herpes two and
that is another film coming out in the
tradition of Mommy Dearest it was
written by a daughter of one of the
three stooges titles surly curly but I
think the most inspired screen pairing
of the year was between Henry Fonda and
Katharine Hepburn I mean it moved
everybody except interior secretary
James Watt who today approved offshore
drilling on Golden Pond
you shouldn't worry he's issued each
duck a dipstick but this is the night
the Hollywood puts aside its petty
jealousies and brings out its major
jealousies and as I look at this
audience tonight I see the directors the
writers the stars the producers and
they're all sitting in Warren Beatty
seat Warren Beatty is the only
individual to be nominated in four
categories for a second time Warren I
Warren I think that's great something
like this could get you girls
the UH Elizabeth Taylor sends her
regrets she could not be here tonight as
you know she's working in London where
she's been joined by Richard Burton and
I know I personally think it's kind of
romantic that Liz and Dick might get
back together again
actually they have to get back together
again they've married everyone else
before we break I would just like to say
a personal thank you to a gentleman who
was in the audience tonight who kind of
set the trend for mastering the
ceremonies of this show for over 20
years mr. Bob Hope
thank you